in the war on ukraine a possible raid on
a russian oil depot is making headlines
this morning a russian official claims
two ukrainian helicopters attacked the
facility some 20 miles across the border
this comes as russian forces continue to
bombard ukrainian cities killing
thousands of civilians in mario pool
yesterday they blocked food and medical
supplies from getting in and refugees
from getting out holly williams is in
central ukraine this morning holly good
morning
good morning we've just shown you that
video that purports to show a ukrainian
attack on a russian oil depot and if
true it's significant but at this point
there's no independent confirmation
in the farming village of malaysia
sternia as in most of ukraine they were
set up to stay here the russian soldiers
were unwelcome visitors so this is where
they slept
the residents have fled but colonel
sergey ramashko told us his men
recaptured marlo sternya five days ago
killing some russians and capturing
others
russian boots
their clothes and shoes are still here
even their cooking pots
colonel ramashko told us the russians
were used as cannon fodder so short of
food they looted from the locals
the russians have war machines ukraine
can only dream of but the ukrainian
soldiers are destroying them including
two armored personnel carriers on this
stretch of road the colonel told us
three russians miraculously escaped from
this one well they were lucky to survive
this and are now being treated in a
ukrainian hospital
we'll defeat them he said i feel
victorious
in the town of urbin just north of
ukraine's capital kiev ukraine's
resistance has also driven back the
russians but this is the cost a line of
body bags slaughtered in what vladimir
putin calls his special military
operation
in malaysia sternia the russians have
also left behind deadly weapons a field
carpeted with anti-tank mines and an rpg
warhead in the front yard of this home
so this is a russian rocket
these families the colonel told us were
fleeing another village even closer to
the front line
vladimir putin has sent his soldiers to
invade a country that only wants to be
free and his war is killing both
ukrainians and russians
russian troops who were occupying the
chernobyl nuclear site have now
withdrawn according to ukrainian
officials and they claim the russian
soldiers received significant doses of
radiation because they dug trenches in
the exclusion zone around the plant
vlad
holly williams reporting from inside
ukraine holly thank you stay safe